so what's up with the whole I don't want
to talk to Mike I don't want to get into
details about like your whole drama
that's going on with the eSports [ __ ]
but I've been I've known kind of I kind
of know like what's been going on for
the past year whatever and it sucks for
both people there's a lot of like
Internet drama going on right now but uh
how are you doing that's good
is it true it's not is it true that you
want to start an eSports company like
your organization I never said that once
I didn't think you did either and
anybody knows right like I would think
someone like you would you know just be
want to focus on your own brand and what
you're doing and and nothing else
right you wouldn't like the last thing
that you would want to do I would think
was like to start a company and try to
run a company yeah I mean you mean you
obviously were an idiot for signing
something yeah young and naive for for
you know doing that but I could imagine
being in that situation you want to
[ __ ] join the cool kids you know you
want to you're you have mean you're like
on the rise you're young and it's like
hey look you can be like this you can do
this you know look at this big mansion
look at all these fancy cars look at
everything we do like yeah complete
until [ __ ] dumbass but the bottom
line is they shouldn't ever gave me a
legal contract to begin with yeah do you
know a lot of a lot of like are you
personally rounds with a lot of players
who are signed like signed contracts for
eSports teams or organizations like that
yeah I mean I have yeah have they
reached out to you have you talked to
them and what do they say I mean I have
kids reaching out to me they're 14 and
15 years old really that are like dude
help me get out of my contract I'm stuck
in there they're all that they don't
even care about me they're trying to
just get me to qualify for World Cup
like kids are getting scammed saying
what do you say to him I don't know I
have too much going on I can't help him
yeah hopefully my situation brings light
to
like that I don't know it's a whole
[ __ ] up situation
yeah for a lot of kids yeah well
hopefully this can shine some some light
on some dark areas and help a lot of
people but a lot of illegal activity
going on in the eSports world yeah
hopefully that comes in and soon yeah
what's the next like what